ich bin ja seit jetzt über 22 Jahren
trocken trockene Alkoholiker ich war 16
Jahre Profi 16 Jahre 14 Jahre
medikamentenabhängig vier Jahre
spielsüchtig habe mich dann da
rausgeholt und bin jetzt unterwegs in
ganz Deutschland Suchtprävention seit 10
Jahren ich bin auf der Straße ich habe
sogar am Experiment teilgenommen und war
im Frankfurter am Main und habe da bei
-16° zweieinhalb Tage Nächte verbracht
und habe mir das Ganze angeschaut es war
absoluter Wahnsinn weil ich selbst weiß
was auf der Straße passiert wir leben in
einem Suchtkranken Land und das ist das
was ich sehe weil ich jeden Tag auf der
Straße bin vor zehn Jahren bin ich
ausgelacht worden weil ich gesagt habe
wir müssen Prävention wir müssen in
Schulen wir müssen mit den Kindern reden
wir müssen mit den Erwachsenen reden wir
Erwachsene sind die Vorbilder für unsere
Kinder und wenn Sie das sehen was da
draußen abgeht das hat nicht mehr viel
mit Vorbild zu tun Menschen die mehr
belastet sind die jeden Tag Druck Hektik
und Stress haben driften ab in